hey guys what's up this is andrew for
jensenses.com so in this video as usual
guys we're gonna go through amc gme
press action we're gonna have a look at
what is happening on the rest of the
market and we're gonna uh also check the
major indicators us 10 yield the dxy and
see what this is telling us let's get
into it
alright guys so let's start with amc so
bam bam bam yesterday in my last video i
told you that we having you know balls
were in control in the short term we
reached the 20-day moving average that
is always a very important moving
average
uh where we had this trend land i
explained to you guys why we use this
trend line um we got rejected here this
is our area of resistance
together with the 13.5 level i told you
yesterday that
bulls
were
in control in the short term but
are a little bit losing control because
we were missing the volume
this was before the close after the
close we can see that the volume
increased actually yesterday on a green
day which is positive
so i would say that bulls are you know
they're they're fighting well that's for
sure are they in control
hard to say i would say neutral on the
short term bearish on the medium term
and like we said
we can say bullish on the long term
because it's amc right
but long-term signals are mixed to be
very honest um
so right now
we are coming to test the turning point
five level we got reject rejected here
today
um so we are still struggling we are
forming forming a nice pattern once
again let me put that in green i prefer
the green
uh because we have a trendline here with
many reactions and we are right now
consolidating just below so you guys
know that whenever we consider we can't
say that just below
uh a resistance on low volume so
usually consider consolidation happens
on low volume uh then a breakout with
increasing volume is a very good bullish
signal so let's see what's going to
happen here um
i have more things to tell you but very
quickly guys i have a big big
announcement to make the crypto bulls
that i'm talking about for quite some
time guys we started this together we
started it on my discord uh with some
ugly designs at the beginning and we
arrived with that guys with the crypto
bulls
uh nft club uh so the the website has
just been released today guys
and i
made a video that i posted on crypto
bulls youtube channel you need to go
check it guys i'm not going to explain
everything here it's a 10 minute video
i'm explaining everything about the
project and we are going to do great
things so
go check this video subscribe to the
crypto booths channel come to the
discord we got a mint in two weeks we
have a very very high engagement because
our art is just amazing
our project is very strong the team is
strong it's gabrielle me my brother my
cousin
we are we're going to you know really
really do amazing things and i really
want you guys to be part of this
adventure because you know that i come
from um
you know training amc i'm going to the
nfcs because there are a lot a lot of
good things to do there and i want you
to to join guys we you know i prepared
everything for you to be welcomed uh to
this new community
and
and once again go check the video i'm
explaining everything most nft projects
seriously is [ __ ] what we are going
to do um is i think pretty unique uh
we're gonna use our skills to grow uh
offend half of the profits uh half of
the funds
from the mint go to
a vault and we're gonna use that to do
crypto arbitrage to make money and to
give this money to charity uh we're also
gonna develop web3 applications we're
gonna basically do something great for
the crypto space so go watch this video
like subscribe to the channel and i hope
i'm gonna see you in the crypto bulls
discord let's get back to amc guys
uh so
like i said here
uh
i mean we need to see what's gonna
happen here a breakout would be perfect
it can very well happen uh once again
it's gonna depend on what is happening
on the rest of the market
um amc cannot you know
go really higher by itself i mean to do
25 to the area if the rest of the market
is bearish this is quite obvious
we can have one day crazy move up if the
rest of the market is tanking but not a
week or a month and this is what we need
like you see to have a nice move up it
develops in you know two three weeks one
month and this was only one wave
so this up is done
and uh bam bam bam so yeah the level to
go through is basically check the 20-day
moving average it's where you have the
resistance area roughly so today at
13.95 94 right now so let's see if we're
able to go above that and once again
it's going to depend on what is
happening with the rest of the market
jamie
so bam bam bam jme we said that we have
better signals on the regular scale so
we come back to the regular scan and
look what we have what i told you guys
this consolidation here
look
one two three four five candles okay
i mean it's undeniable that this is a
consolidation that is happening on low
volume just below a resistance right and
for those who followed my course that is
still available
uh you know guys that this is what we're
looking for and we just need a breakout
with increasing volume so let's see if
we can have it and once again it's gonna
probably go together with the rest of
the markets but we can very well have an
early signal on uh jmu amc
that could be used on the rest of the
market but i usually prefer to get
signals from the global market and to
apply it to amc and jamie so here the
level to go through is the 95 level and
as you see we have the 20 day moving
average a little bit above at 111 right
now and we have the 105 resistance so
let's say that we have here a double
resistance to go through
uh 95 first step second step 105 and
probably if we reach 105 the 20 day
moving average that is decreasing right
now as you can see would probably be
here as well so i would say that the
second resistance is 105 and this is
what we would need for boots to you know
start getting back into this area that
is a nice area between 130 and 160 will
have a lot a lot of resistance but if we
arrive there strongly with increasing
volume we can um
you know have some nice moves so now
let's analyze the rest of the market
that is going to tell us if all of that
is likely to happen or not
so
like i said i missed my bearish trade i
have of course still a short position
that i'm happy to keep
i wanted to increase it i missed it
sorry for you guys in my discord that
followed my alert because
you know usually i'm quite accurate with
triple q
not this time but whatever
it's okay missing a trade is not like
losing money
missing a winning trade of course
uh so here i'm not taking profits i'm
just letting it go because i'm afraid
that we do something like that okay this
can be put in red
all right so if we do that of course
it's not good for mcnjme
so basically i'm using that as a trigger
to tell me that the correction might be
behind us okay and the trigger is gonna
be
given i mean the signal is going to be
given whenever we're going to go through
this trend line all right and once again
as you can see the 20-day moving average
is exactly on the trend line right now
okay it's very often happening you have
those two
uh resistance that are done using trend
lines all right and moving averages that
usually you know kind of converge you
know and
are giving the same levels and this is a
stronger resistance so right now it's
310. so this is where i wanted to sell
of course yesterday today
i didn't send an any alert about that
because
uh
i mean we are too far from it right so
if we came back to it around the 310
level i would probably post an alert
but once again you guys know that i
don't like to sell a level or buy a
level when the resistance or the support
has been tested multiple times in a
short period of time because it makes it
weaker so here we tested it not long ago
so if we tested today or tomorrow i'm
not sure i'm gonna sell here so for now
i don't post any alerts i rather would
like to make the opposite trade which
would be that
bam
okay wait for the breakout
you can see we have nice decreasing
volume that's very good by the way i
have not noticed that
yesterday move was happening on low
volume that's quite bullish all right
look here's the high volume in the way
down
correction low volume makes sense and
then we go again so usually we're gonna
we should have had an increasing volume
here we didn't so this is a good sign
for bulls it's not enough but it's a
good sign
so this scenario is losing a little bit
of weight i was saying 70 i think or 60
let's say it's a 55 or 60 today
um
i'm not going to trade here i'm only
going to buy at 270 the first time we go
here because we're probably gonna have a
bullish reaction if we come here we can
we could very well
you know uh just start to be bullish
again
uh and this is what i'm gonna play if
we're bullish i'm gonna wait for the
breakout and i'm gonna
take profit on my short position here
all right
on the retest
so this is my view let's check now the
usual indicators that are giving good
signs uh us 10 year yield as you guys
know we are following that for quite
some time and below the breakout level
was at 285 we are today at 283 guys so
we are slightly below let's observe this
quick you know uh closer but for now
we're still above so i mean for now the
usual scenario the most likely scenario
just looking at that is re-test and we
go higher right
and here
we are re-testing the level
uh we are still in the danger zone to me
so
if i only look at this chart to me do
you know we are bullish and we should go
higher if this happens we're going to
crash so i'm monitoring that but we're
coming back to levels that are
acceptable for the market all right we
used to trade at 285 last year here
here
uh bam bam bam okay
it's not last year this was 2 18 sorry
and kovid was where kovid was marched
when he was here all right
so but this was a completely different
situation so now we have one because
here we have deflection deflation so in
a deflationary environment rates crash
during a crisis but in an inflationary
environment rates go up in a crisis that
it's like that uh you know i could
explain but it would take a little uh
too long i'm explaining that i have
explained that many times in previous
videos as well you can go and check
any triple q video uh but whatever let's
get back to it so it's pretty
positive
uh ndxy
same guys i told you 103 is the level to
watch we were above
we are coming back below
so
we can very well go higher again which
would not be good for the market but if
we're coming back below the
103 level it's quite good
so we have positive signals from the two
indicators but they are still giving a
bearish environment signal let's be very
clear on that
dxy gives me bearish signal uh
rates us 10 yield gives me bear signal
we are bearish
definitely on triple q
and we are only slightly bullish on the
short term on mcn gme so we are still in
a very bearish environment uh very
fragile very dangerous so
that's why let's be careful stay close
to show as i explained before guys don't
try to play the hero
and that's it for today so do not forget
guys to go and check this video about
crypto bulls link in the description
subscribe to the crypto bulls channel
join us on discord uh you're gonna be
well treated coming from trading census
channel trust me about that and once
again we are going to do great things i
want you to be part of it so that's it
for today i hope you enjoyed this video
and don't forget as well to click on the
sub
like and bell button if you have not
already and stay close to show see you
guys